let's talk about the F word feminism it
represents a movement that's been
bad-mouth since it came on the scene
despite is huge impact on the world
feminism is a belief in gender equality
political economic and social and yet
only 20% of Americans say they're
feminists even though 82% say they
believe in gender equality what gives is
this a question of branding or is all
this one giant misunderstanding here are
the five biggest myths about feminism
there's a been there done that idea
thanks to women's rights movements women
not all but many around the world can
vote own property open a bank account
and hold all kinds of jobs so what's
left to fight for misogyny is still
alive and well which means feminism is
still needed
so misogyny or hatred of women hasn't
gone anywhere and neither has unequal
pay for every dollar that a man earns in
an hour a woman earns eighty four cents
and only eight percent of the top execs
of the 500 most traded companies are
women and ending violence against women
continues to be an ongoing fight even in
a suppose in the equal country like the
u.s. one in five women have been raped
and ninety-eight percent of rapists are
men then there's the people who say
feminism is a girl thing but if feminism
is just for women that would mean ending
sexism is women's responsibility alone
and by the same logic ending racism is
only the job of people of color how does
that work especially when it comes to
ending violence against women so guess
what guys you too can be a feminist and
as Nigerian author Chimamanda Adichie
said a feminist is a man or a woman who
says yes there's a problem with gender
as it is today and we must fix it we
must do better
welcome some people fear that feminists
want an estrogen World Order we're
Fembots controlled by femme Nazis make
men wash endless
mountains of dishes sorry what it's just
not true maybe the real fear is
upsetting the status quo and guess what
even if you don't identify as male or
female feminism is for you to feminist
naysayers point to their lipstick and
high heels as badges of their anti
feminism but get this if anything
feminism is about giving women the show
it should you know be whatever kind of
person they would like to be masculine
or somewhere in between another
misconception is that feminism is
against things like marriage and
motherhood also not true throughout the
years feminists have fought against
pregnancy discrimination in the
workplace and better conditions for
working moms and if being feminine to
you means loving liquid liner take a
page from this feminist and go for it
whenever you're applying your eyeshadow
think of it like the glass ceiling the
center the better finally there's the
idea that feminists don't look like me
they're imagined as old white and
middle-class but there are feminists of
every race age class sexuality
nationality and gender so the next time
someone says to you I'm not a feminist
but do them a favor and pass this along
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook